[Music]
welcome to
medphysics morality and mayhem most
philosophers
have thought our account of the world
must precede our conclusions about how
we should act
metaphysics before morality now in an
era where there's deep puzzlement about
what the overall framework might be
it begins to look as if we need to know
what we want to do
and achieve before we can decide on what
a counter world we might adopt
should we put morality first and decide
how we want to change the world before
framing our theories to understand it
or is this profoundly mistaken and a
quick route
to conflict division and chaos
well with me to discuss this i've got a
great panel
to explore what is a deep and
fundamental question
simon blackburn is a leading philosopher
and what is sometimes known as the
analytics school
he's written many books a number on
truth and also on morality
both of course central to today's debate
and he describes himself as being a
quasi-realist
about meta-ethical issues and no doubt
we'll hear
further from him what he means by that
in today's conversation
joanna cavanagh is an award-winning
writer and acclaimed novelist
and her novels are wide-ranging and
structurally adventurous
including inglorious and the field guide
to reality
in which a philosopher has put together
a vast compendium of thought
to fix existential angst the book
however
has gone missing and all the characters
are trying to find it
a metaphor no doubt for this debate
and raymond talis who following a
successful career as a physician and
clinical neuroscientist
has metamorphosed into a prolific writer
having published i think more than
20 books on wide-ranging topics from
poetry to philosophy
his latest seeing ourselves reclaiming
humanity from god and science
was published earlier this year now
in the usual way i'm going to give each
of them three minutes for the overall
response to the question
must we decide our morality uh in
advance
of framing the theories that we have to
understand the world
so simon we're going to kick off with
you it's all yours
if we start with the everyday um we're
all capable of making descriptions about
the world
which show nothing to our moralities um
i'm sitting in a room i've got a
television in front of me there's a
carpet on the floor light over there
it's a sunny day and so forth my senses
give me that
um maybe there's an interpretation of my
experience going on in fact
you know the old philosophers would say
there it is but the interpretation
doesn't on the face of it seem to owe
anything to morality
you can't tell from my description of my
room whether i'm a
a great fan of boris johnson and a
passionate defender of dominic cummings
or whether i'm quite sensible
when we look at high-level scientific
theory
it's also very difficult to see morality
getting into it
i mean if you look at the great quantum
theorists einstein was left-wing
pacifist um heisenberg was not
and neil's ball was different again they
all had their
moral and political differences um but
they all agreed about
science so it's very difficult to see
that the
high-level theories of that kind
and those are the best we have um owe
anything very much to morality or
politics
well of course they are something to
politics in this instance if the
political situation gets bad enough
uh the science stops being practiced as
it had to be
so um so i think that the
um initial answer this is why i was a
bit puzzled about the question
the little answer i'm going to give is
that the um
the ball is in the camp of those who
think that morality does
uh inevitably affect infect our
world well so
um as you said hillary in your opening
remarks there's kind of a suggestion
that where formerly we might have
contemplated the world deeply in the
world of universals and then worked out
what to do
um now there's a concern that many
people don't hold a belief in
a religious universal view so how do we
act and do we then reverse the whole
thing and we decide we're just going to
act and stop with the contemplation
and i wonder if it's all that neat if it
was ever a case that there was on one
side
absolute that existed beyond language
and on the other side um these
contingent mores because
even if the super beings are present and
you know we can't know for certain
they're not then do they use human
language do they use our concepts
and the concepts themselves are deeply
rooted in human lives in contingent
realities metaphysics
doesn't originally mean as we understand
it something beyond the physical world
it comes we think and we don't know for
certain but
some poor editor in the first century bc
trying to deal with aristotle's work
and he suggests some of the works might
be filed as
tameta tar physica the ones after the
ones about nature
and from this we have this wonderful
change through history as language
changes and we now have a different
sense but equally
morality again if we try to cite it in
the world
cicero may have been the first person
who coined it again he's trying to
translate from the greek he's trying to
go into
um trying to translate ethicos
um and he reaches for a word we don't
know the origin or the latin word
moss which in its plural form means
mores the customs
and so we're within the contingent world
all the time and language
changes in time it changes its meaning
words aren't these stable absolutes and
they're not gifts from
a realm beyond language that sounds very
paradoxical
um so i think the question though you
ask about foundation and how to act is
really crucial though
um because if you're going to act in a
reality you
do need to have a kind of sense of
certain questions that have a partial or
contingent answer
what is the reality that i'm dealing
with in some sense you need to answer
that
and who am i that must deal with this
reality
and again to answer them absolutely you
need to be eternal and omniscient you
need to be in all realities at all times
um so we can't do that but there's a
danger then we end up very discouraged
we end up like bartleby the scrivener
who can't do
anything um or we end up uh like murso
in lestrange who thinks because
everything's meaningless you can
act without meaning you may as well and
he kills a man
for no meaning so there's great peril
and importance to this question um and
to offer
one i'm running out of time but to offer
one very again to use the word
contingent
possible answer um there's another novel
by camu which is highly relevant to
today
lapes the plague which he publishes in
1947
and in this he gives his most
interesting character
ria a possible answer to the question
the two questions really that i posed
um what is this reality well it's a
plague
and people are suffering appallingly and
who am i well ria is a doctor
and he has a relative role a very
important role
in that reality to save lives to reduce
suffering
and he hasn't answered the vast
questions of what is everything
but he can act he can act in this
tragedy and in a sense camus is saying
because he has this role
he is in a sense of fortunate man so
i mean that i think we're in a certain
amount of existential mayhem whatever we
do because of these very strange and
uncertain conditions of our existence
but i suspect we're trying for the least
mayhem
for ourselves
words create worlds and i think also
change
in relation to the world and i'd say
actually though i don't have time to
advance this philosophy is a kind of art
in this respect
borrowing a bit from iris murdoch who
borrowed a bit from wittgenstein
because it does precisely that it
creates this world
thank you uh joe and uh
ray do you uh do you want to put your
point of view please
as a non-professional philosopher i've
often been disappointed by the lack of
connection between the most interesting
parts
of philosophy metaphysics and ethics how
they don't
connect uh in in any obvious way rather
as simon said
um and this of course as again what
simon said it's a contrast to religion
where an account of the fundamental
nature of the universe is inextricably
connected
with the way we should behave mediated
through a god
but in the other hand it's one of the
glories of philosophy but it's not in a
hurry to be useful
its curiosity is boundless and the way
it pursues its enquiries is not
compromised
by the desire to find a solution to the
parochial problems
of how human beings should get on with
one another
and it's perhaps important to understand
why this failure to connect
ethics and let's say metaphysics is not
an accident
we have to remind ourselves what
metaphysic covers its boundaries are
fluffy of course
but most philosophers would agree uh
that it deals with
fundamental things such as space and
time the stuff of the universe such as
mind and matter
causation necessity substance attributes
and so on
and you don't have to have a clear idea
of what these are and conclude that they
have
little or nothing to do with morality to
continue watching this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai dot tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas
you